so morality is supposed to be about
helping other people being kind to them
about
resolving important social problems but
what grandstanders do
is they turn morality into just an
opportunity to show other people
how good they are and you know what an
achievement for for me to have such pure
moral beliefs but this is an
empty achievement and it's actually kind
of pathetic if you think about it that
way
i'm joined by justin tosi justin welcome
to the show
thanks for having me chris pleasure to
have you
on grandstanding what is grandstanding
yeah so if you want just a bumper
sticker
description of the idea moral
grandstanding is the use of moral talk
for self-promotion
so if you see people on your social
media feeds or you just encounter
people in everyday life who are you know
walking around
talking like corporate press releases or
sounding like politicians giving these
carefully crafted
statements about you know how they've
long stood on
on the side of the disadvantaged and and
so on and
kind of making moral talk about them and
turning it into a vanity project
or a big show where they're the main
character
that's grandstanding why do they do it
so human beings uh care a lot about what
other people
think about them we're all impression
managers so they're
are really fun social science studies
showing that you know if you tell people
um you know i'm going to leak to the
university community that you got this
really bad score on this uh this
implicit association test that reveals
uh perhaps
racial bias they will do horrible things
you know that you'd see on fear factor
or whatever sticking their hands in a
bowl of worms and you know nasty stuff
like that
because they care a lot about what their
communities think of them they don't
want to be ostracized
and they all know that if people think
um
you know that they are not very good
people morally
that they run the risk of being kind of
run out of their friend groups or their
their political groups things like this
people are also
self-enhancers uh so we all
like to think that we are morally good
uh and morally above average all of us
so we kind of have this impression of
ourselves you know
i'm better than the average person um
my heart is is really in the right place
and we want other people to share that
impression
so we take steps to present a flattering
picture of ourselves
to the world and that's why we engage in
grandstanding because it's a very easy
way to show people that our heart is in
in the right place so why not do it
it seems like there's kind of two types
of grandstanding there one of them is
like defensive grandstanding and the
other is offensive grandstanding is that
kind of right
yeah so uh psychologists talk about
two different ways that people seek
status
on the one hand people sometimes seek
status through prestige
so this is when people try to present
some characteristic of themselves
that actually deserves praise that is
impressive
so um in the non-moral realm this is is
uh
people uh who you know post flattering
pictures of
themselves on an instagram uh or my new
benchpress pr this is my new yeah
my fast car my big house my good looking
girlfriend
yeah yeah so these are things that that
it's actually you know
like that makes sense that the people
would admire these things
uh so people will sometimes seek status
uh in this way they'll seek prestige
status
sometimes people uh will also seek
status
through dominance so they'll present
themselves as someone
not or someone to be reckoned with
someone not to be messed with
um so they'll go after people they'll uh
you know try to embarrass or humiliate
people that they don't like
uh and their hope um implicit or not
is that people will stay away from them
not mess with them
think this is not someone i want to piss
off i want to stay on this person's good
side
and this is another way of kind of
gaining respect of
gaining the esteem of others through
being really aggressive
so you can grandstand in both of these
ways uh the prestige way
is often a bit more defensive as as you
put it so sometimes
people won't be setting out really uh to
impress people but
an opportunity will arise and they'll
think well i don't want people to think
that uh
my heart is not in the right place about
this issue so i'd better say something
uh right where i i don't want to be
accused of
remaining silent or something like this
and so doing violence or
whatever people are are saying now uh
white silence is violence or whatever so
so they'll do a little bit of
grandstanding uh because hey
what's the harm uh but then there are
people who
uh will go out and um you know go
looking for a fight
look look for someone uh who's kind of
like straying from the pack a little bit
and making themselves vulnerable uh the
person who uh
who doesn't put their fists up at the
restaurant
uh outdoors that's happened in
washington dc recently
um and you know these are the people you
go after so you can do a bit of
grandstanding uh
about you know look i'm out here leading
this group of people all
making this gesture why aren't you doing
it like what's wrong with you
um so uh the people doing that can can
also gain
a kind of status and so they do so all
of this can can be
grandstanding do you think that some of
the people who are choosing to play that
game
choosing to play the moral grandstanding
armchair philosophizing side uh
do you think that they will skew toward
people who can't use prestige and
typical forms of wealth and dominance
to move up the hierarchy so if you have
someone who isn't potentially very good
looking or
doesn't really have that much wealth or
actually isn't all that clever but has
what i call
podcast podcast wits which is that
they're able to say
they're able to say something which
gives this the representation of looking
smart
um they might think hang on i can't
compete in the typical
dominance hierarchy i'm going to change
the rules of the game
you want to play chess i want to play
rugby let's play rugby
yeah so i like this a lot you're hitting
on a kind of pet theory of
of mine which is uh that that a lot of
people who engage in grand scheme if
they actually had any anything
interesting to say like if they were
actually funny uh
or if they had something else going for
them
that's what they would do right they
would just be funny or they would just
just show their their wealth so they'd
engage in some conspicuous consumption
or something like that but but they
don't or
that or it's so much easier for them to
engage in moral grandstanding
that that's you know just a very simple
reliable path
to status for them uh so that's the
stuff that they do instead
our mutual fan uh friend rob henderson
has has written
stuff about this about his [ __ ] king
of conspicuous consumption and this
yeah high status goods at the moment
that he's playing around with
uh luxury yeah beliefs um sorry
sorry man so he draws the stuff uh from
veblen uh who has this whole theory
worked out so vevlin is
um just this academic outsider
he doesn't fit in in all the elite
circles he doesn't have all the servants
and he's kind of puzzled by uh this
world
so you know he writes this this great
book um
the theory of the leisure class all
about their their kind of lame
practices just you know acquiring
obscure languages and engaging in in all
this pomp
uh and circumstance is to show people
they have the time and
and the money um so
you know uh what rob points out and then
we're kind of
brandon and i are in this same vein um
is that people do this also with their
moral beliefs
so they'll they'll claim at least um and
very often i think they actually do have
the beliefs um
but they'll at least claim to to have
these flattering beliefs and they'll get
status for it
um and and you know so sometimes this is
because they have nothing else going for
them sometimes it seems like this is
just the precondition for being accepted
into polite society
so there's stuff recently maybe you saw
this about woke fishing
so um people claiming you know
very disappointed you know women say you
know i went on a date
with this guy and he said he was you
know
a good progressive he had he said all
the right things but then it turned out
he wasn't super progressive
and so people are you know turning this
into this great conspiracy that these
these guys are all out there um
you know pretending to be really woke uh
and and they're not
uh i think actually a better explanation
for this is just that people don't
really think these words mean very much
uh and
they're just you know they know if i'm
in polite society these are the things i
have to claim to believe and then but
then you get them like
you know one or two deductions away from
the thing that they claim to believe
it's like whoa
what like what's the difference between
woke fishing
and the vast majority of people who are
playing around with these brand new
rules that six weeks ago
were completely acceptable and today is
completely unacceptable or the reverse
like the fact that you believe that you
believe
doesn't make doesn't mean that you
actually [ __ ] believe it
like it's just that your self-deception
is so pervasive that the guy who's using
woke fishing
has weaponized your miscalculation of
how you see things
i i put it in i put the work fishing
thing in a newsletter recently
and um thankfully i think in the uk we
don't have that same polarization
um at least not in not in quite the same
way
um but yeah i think robert put was it
rob that had identified
any guy who has moderate in their
tinder profile has to be a republican
that sounds like something wrong so like
the the set point basically of where
people
guys are expected to be now on the
tinder spectrum
is that because of walk fishing you need
to be like super super progressive
just to be centrist and like anything
short of that is like a gun-toting nra
hick that loves country music and drives
a pickup truck
like that's yeah that's it um but dude
the work fishing thing's great have you
got some
some examples for people you mentioned
this recent
incident where there was a lady sat down
at a restaurant
and you've got tons and tons of examples
let's give the
listeners some concrete examples of what
happens what grandstanding can actually
look like when it manifests
yeah so let me run through it in the
book we give you uh
we give everybody this this field guide
um the things that people do when they
grandstand
so to be clear uh it's not the case that
like every time
anyone does something on this list they
are grandstanding
right it's it's rather that when people
are grandstanding these are the kinds of
things that they tend to do
so just to interject them and that's the
point the point
is that it's a trojan horse it's you
weaponizing a particular world view
point of view that other people
hold truthfully but it's you doing it in
a way
which is um uh metacognitively kind of
uh labored right you're doing it for the
effect
rather than the fact that you are
compelled and you genuinely believe it
yeah that's very close so actually
we think that you can really believe the
things uh
and then and in fact when we can get to
this this is
why uh some of this is so dangerous
because if people were actually just
bullshitting
right then it wouldn't be so bad if
they're claiming to believe these these
crazy things
but because they believe it then it
takes on this new dimension
it's not just like people jerking off in
public it's it's like
whoa like so much more driving opinion
yeah right okay so the framework tell us
yeah yeah uh so one of the things that
people tend to do
which i'm sure everyone has seen is that
they'll engage in piling on
so look for a case of someone who's
violated a norm in public
um social media is you know the perfect
uh
forum for for this and they'll see
people
getting in their digs at this person and
they'll say you know either something
that everyone
you know someone has said a hundred
times already or they'll they'll attempt
some new form of abuse
uh to to mock this person and they'll do
this
to show other people uh that they are
in the right on on this issue that they
uh they're part of the crowd
that they're not you know um cautious
you know they're not sitting on the
sidelines they agree with
everyone else about how bad this person
is um
another thing that people will do is
that they will engage in what we call
ramping up so this is when moral talk
becomes a kind of arms race
with people uh looking to say the most
extreme
thing that the crowd will will still
uh think of as as morally impressive
so in in the us uh i don't know if this
just
this discourse has reached the uk but um
you know with with all of these
uh protests people started uh
really hitting this point you know we
need to defund the police
uh and very quickly that this became uh
you know we need to actually abolish the
police so we think you know within a
matter of 48 hours this move
from like you know we need to take a
good look at how we're funding these
organizations like get rid of them
entirely and that's of course what we
meant
all along right so so this is i think
part of the dynamic that you were
hitting on earlier
of things you know moving so quickly and
it's like people haven't thought this
out
um and it's and it's because um
grandstanders have an incentive
uh to be really extreme and you know
make the splashy claim that will will
then become the official statement that
everyone you know argues about it and
says
like this is whoa this guy's really you
know out there or whatever
another thing that people will do is
they'll engage in trumping up
so they'll make exotic moral claims uh
and the idea here is um you know a lot
of people might have overlooked
this problem but i'm really sensitive
or i'm really knowledgeable about about
justice and how morality works
so i saw this and everyone else should
take notice
right so if there's an incentive to do
this you'll get people becoming really
creative
and and saying things uh that are just
way
out there because it will impress at
least some members of
of their group you'll also have people
engaged in what we call excessive
emotional displays
so these are the people you might be
thinking of who are just always outraged
about whatever the latest thing is um
and it's always
at 10 or 11 right like so they're always
going to 11.
um because they want to be seen as like
the most
like sensitive the people who care the
most about
justice uh and then finally
grandstanders are really often
dismissive of people who disagree with
them so they'll say
things like look if you don't see what's
so bad about this chris
i don't even what i don't know what to
tell you man like you're just too far
gone
you are too in the dark you need to do
some work on yourself
and then you know then we can talk or
whatever but it's not my job to educate
you
educate yourself right so stuff like
this and the idea here is like
i can't i'm so good i can't even put
myself in the frame of mind
of someone like you so i wouldn't know
where to start
uh so you know you can grant in other
ways too
right uh any anything that is moral talk
could in principle be grandstanding
people could be driven to say it uh by
um a desire to impress others
uh but these are just some some really
common things that that people
tend to do i mean that just sounds to me
like a matrix
breaking down the like vast majority of
tweets with more than 5 000 likes that
i've seen
during 2020. like if it's broken 5 000
likes and it isn't macaulay culkin
telling us that he's 40.
like it's probably one of those tweets
um yeah
so is grandstanding a new phenomenon
is it just another byproduct of social
media
or how does new technology link in with
all the things
that you've just said so when you asked
why people do it i referred to some just
common traits of
human beings that we care what other
people think of us
and we think well of ourselves and want
other people to share that impression
so those are not new traits um those are
things that have probably been with us
as as long as we have been recognizably
human working together and caring
about whether we can trust one another
so the ingredients to grandstand
have been with us for a very long time
and we think there is
indeed nothing new about the idea
or really about the behavior what is new
is that it's now so much easier
for people to grandstand it's basically
costless
so you just pick up your phone and you
have an audience you know depending on
on how
interesting and attractive you are and
all these things you have an audience of
hundreds to thousands to millions of
people uh who are just ready to gobble
up
whatever it is that you say uh
and moral terms
uh moral uh you know especially
emotionally charged
uh moral claims that people might make
online
there's good social science showing
these are great ways to get attention
so what social media does is that it
removes
so much of the cost of grandstanding
because you don't have to go anywhere
to do it uh and it also makes it
uh well both yeah so sorry
i'm being an academic about yeah yeah
yeah i just wonder about the difference
between the the cost
and the effort there because the cost of
getting grandstanding
wrong online saying the thing you
thought might be different to the effort
required to do it does that make sense
good point yeah that's right so yeah so
i
i mean so i was thinking mostly of
effort yeah but you're right
uh it also probably changes the way
people grant santa it probably makes
them
more careful about it so that's why so
they have something called the long
caption that you're no doubt familiar
with chris what's up
oh yeah uh maybe this is not a thing um
i i thought this is
so it's when uh people on instagram will
post like a thirst trap
picture uh and then they'll have a long
caption about whatever social justice
issue or or yeah i do that
i am a i am an absolute you have a law
i'm captioned
i'm patient i'm patient zero for that
but it won't be
it won't be social justice posturing
it'll be
like first trap photo um i have a new
podcast episode now live with justin
tosi
link in bio there you go um like that's
okay
right all right fine i mean if i'm if
i'm part of the cool kids crowd
that's really all that i care about man
i just don't want to feature in
grandstanding 2.0
yeah so i think that goes to
the theory that we were talking about
before i mean so you have you have
something to offer people it's actually
interesting you have a podcast
where you have brilliant people on and
and talk to them about about their books
and and whatever else um people actually
want to hear about
uh but if you don't have anything like
that you have nothing to promote uh you
can further promote yourself
by uh by writing up some some mealy
mouth like really carefully measured
because again you don't wanna
to make people mad and incur some
further cost um
uh so right so what uh the other thing
that social media adds
is it just makes it so hard to avoid
uh other people's grandstanding right so
before you could just like not go to
political rallies or not go to that one
coffee shop in the college town or
whatever
but now it's like you know somebody's
mom is just like won't shut up about
whatever is
is in the news and she wants everybody
to know that you know she's long stood
with
uh the oppressed and so on and so we see
grandstanding everywhere
uh so that's what's new i guess is just
the platform makes it so easy um
yeah it's uh it's an
interesting thing to think about what
social media has done
to people's desire for people's desire
to signal
right because everyone now essentially
is their own brand
like you wear a nike t-shirt or an added
ass t-shirt or this t-shirt or that
t-shirt and immediately people are
saying okay
what does that say about you that you
wore that thing
what does that say about that brand that
they are the sort of brand that is worn
by that sort of a person
and the same thing happens with
intellectual arguments and concepts and
political affiliations and
your favorite netflix series that you
talk about online and everything
now is an opportunity to self-brand and
i had
um a couple of years ago i had robin
hansen elephant in the brain
on talking about everything is signaling
and increasingly
i just realized that robin hansen was
always right that it's just
signaling all over the place and that's
it yeah
yeah so it's all signaling and it's all
like this is what [ __ ] sucks so much
about it
is it's also uh all an opportunity to
pick someone apart
and like nitpick every so i mean i'm
sure you you you get this
like you're more active on social media
than than i am which is not saying a lot
but i mean you probably get i actually
saw some last some
just like ridiculous responses of people
like um
i think some guy said you needed a bra
or something like that yeah yeah that
was yeah
yeah i mean to be fair to be fair he was
right um
but you know i can't i can't abuse a guy
but i think uh
there's a few different there's a few
different types of moral grandstanding
the reason that i'm particularly
concerned
about this uh iteration of it
is that when you get a
sufficiently large minority of people
speaking
sufficiently loudly they can shift the
overton window
of acceptable speech in a direction that
i actually think it's really difficult
to bring it back from
like it's now quite hard to have a
discussion
online saying well is
being pro-choice actually that smart of
an idea or is there a discussion to be
had about being pro-life now around
abortion
like that if you dig into some of the
especially ben shapiro's arguments
around it is really really compelling
but to say it is like a moral
grandstanding
uh putting like lighting a flare or
attaching yourself
with one of those laser pointer things
that the drones
fire in on um and that's like the so the
overton window for people who don't know
it's
um basically a particular window of
acceptable speech and you can swing
you can speak within this window but if
you move too far to the conservative or
too far to the progressive side outside
of that window
you tend to be like ostracized by
society and they say oh
like what are you talking about like um
here's an interesting one actually i
wanted to ask i've had it in my head for
a little while
peter thiel during job applications asks
people
what is a belief that you hold that most
of the people
think is untrue have you got one off the
top of your head can you think of one
that fits that
uh oh man i'm gonna get in trouble um
i get not off the top of my head i'll
give you an example i'll give you mine
so mine is
that um paedophiles who don't act on
their urges requests
require sympathy not militant uh
responses
and this came after a conversation with
a neuroscientist
who taught me that um we don't have
control conscious control over our
sexual urges
which means that essentially people who
are
um aroused by children have been cursed
with this thing that they can't act on
and that if you have a society which
demonizes them
um ahead of them doing any actions
what's illegal is the action not the
actual
thought right because you have the
attraction you can't control the
attraction
um and as soon as i had that i was like
i
i there is not there is no other
reasonable solution to this
other than that if anyone is listening
and they're interested and go wants to
go back and listen to it uh it was the
seven deadly sins episode around about
170 something like that
um so that was one thing but basically
but
my point there is that we're mimetic
beings and this is the reason that peter
thiel puts it in his
uh job application is he's constantly
looking for people who are outliers who
are prepared to see outside of the
overton window
and by us being the medic beings the the
beauty of that question what is a belief
that you hold that most
other people think is untrue or
abhorrent or weird or wrong
and you know thinking in that sort of a
way
allows you to say actually that person
has a very unique worldview they have
this different
um but yet to get back to the overt
window thing people can
if you have a big enough majority of
people they can shift the entire
window of acceptable speech so that
something last week which was you see
this with
um the way that you may now have to
refer to
transitioning men and women online
uh the all of the different terms to do
with people
who have uh different uh sexual
orientations to do with different gender
identities to do with this
it's like if you do it for long enough
people kind of can't remember the old
thing it's
very 1984. yeah um
yeah that's that's all really good um
so one of the things that uh we talk
about in the field guide
uh to grant scene is this thing i called
ramping up uh and i think
uh ramping up explains why
the overton window can shift as it does
right because you'll
i mean as you say you get just a group
of people who are loud enough
uh and they keep um you know they circle
around this extreme moral view
um you now you know once it catches on
you can't say anything to them uh that's
very far from
that position so so i mean you can have
multiple phenomena here
one is you can shift the window to be
wider
right because you'll have multiple
groups
polarizing in this way and so like we
now have to talk about all of their
beliefs and i think that can be fine
right like
some extreme views it's actually really
helpful to talk about them
um but you can also uh have multiple
overton windows where it's it's like
um you know in front of this one public
right because you can have a divided
public um
it's only this thing that can be talked
about in front of this other public it's
only this business so
you know you said um you can't talk
about like the ben shapiro views on
abortion with the pro-choice people
you've you know you also can't talk
about some of the pro-choice arguments
with the people who really like the ben
shapiro stuff so this really sucks
like ships in the night passing past
each other you've got one group which is
speaking about
one problem another group which is
speaking about another but again ben
shapiro has a wonderful bit about this
where he talks about
how in the pro-choice pro-life
abortion argument one group is talking
about
rape cases and incest and the other
group is talking about um girls that go
out and get drunk
um every weekend and just use it
willy-nilly
it's like those aren't mapping onto each
other you're talking about one thing and
you're talking about another
and these two groups don't even actually
ever end up interacting
yeah neither group wants to talk about
the others hard case for
their view and that's a real loss
everything's in the middle
the same goes with the gun rights right
like it's one person's talking about
should you be able to have an ar-15 with
a semi-automatic turning stock on the
back
and the other person's saying well i
just want someone like i want to have a
handgun that can protect myself in the
home
like those aren't the same they're not
talking about the same thing
yeah yeah and uh i mean and like you
said earlier
if you try to stake out some position in
the middle where you actually want to
talk about
uh a sensible like nuanced view it's
like you're
you're making your you know you're
putting a target on your back right so
you're putting
chum in the water i get to introduce
even more metaphors for for
both sides right and they're they're
both just like i mean look if we can
agree on anything it's this guy sucks
because he's not you
but he's not us douglas murray hit the
nail on the head about this
in a conversation i had with him and he
said that
a subtle or nuanced view to
the opposition seems like a lack of
conviction
about your ideology wholesale
yeah i think that's totally right so one
thing that we talk about
in the book is what psychologists call
the black cheap effect
uh so the black sheep effect is this
kind of strange on the face of
phenomenon
of people really disliking
the uh the kind of weakly committed
members of their group um so
the way it works is they see these
people as not trustworthy
right so they think like they don't
really get the principles
so um in the u.s uh
i mean i'm sure there are examples of
this in in the uk in uk politics too
um you know john mccain used to be this
guy who like
the democrats actually kind of liked him
he's a he was a republican senator the
democrats are like this guy's okay
you know because sometimes he votes with
us but the republicans whenever john
mccain
would would defection like this son of a
[ __ ] like this guy
we can't count on this guy for anything
um right
so he's their black sheep so no one
wants to be the black sheep of their
group because they know
then that makes them like you know uh
well the black sheep right it makes
people
not like them not trust them and so it
this is why it's so dangerous for people
uh to express any doubt about the
strongly held
beliefs of their group so they
grandstand instead
jordan peterson in his conversation with
the lady from gq
that was like when they got that uh
kathy newman
and they sent her away it wasn't cathy
newman but it was like they'd sent kathy
newman away
put her on a course of steroids and
research for like six months and then
she she came back like we've made her
stronger faster bigger
and uh and he
does this wonderful point where he says
i shouldn't be able to guess the rest of
your views when i only know one of them
and that appears to be the converse of
what we're discussing here
that you need someone to take their
ideology wholesale not piecemeal
and the reason for that is that it
allows the rest of the tribe to better
predict their future behavior
look we don't need to worry about jim
jim's [ __ ] sweet it's
tom that we need to worry about because
tom likes
free markets but actually he's
pro-choice or tom
likes restricted gun control but
actually he's a little bit more
right-leaning or what do you know
whatever it might be um because it's the
[ __ ] in the armor
right yeah uh so this is this is just
such a puzzle to me to like
anyone who's like ever read philosophy
it's like well hold on
like your position on free markets and
your position on abortion
these things should have almost nothing
to do with each other
right but in general if you find out
what someone thinks
about the one thing um you pretty much
you can guess pretty reliably what they
think about
the other thing um so how can we explain
this i mean
so it's it's just it seems because the
ideas aren't aren't really doing the
driving here
it's it's the tribalism uh it's that
people
you know they might feel really strong
about the one issue and then they fall
in with a group
uh who feel strongly about that issue
and then they have all these other
commitments
and in order to remain like in in the
good graces of this group
people have to even some belief uh in
all of the other
orthogonal issues that um that are
popular
uh or you know that people tend to take
a a particular position on within
their network and that can continue to
go further and further toward the
extreme and drag other people with it
and i guess this is where you get sort
of silent majorities
uh brett weinsteiner eric weinstein had
a wonderful point about this where he
said
the problem with the left at the moment
is that the
moderate left is allowing the extreme
left to do the work for them and not
speaking up about it now that is
silences compliance with the extreme
people on your side
like you can't expect people on the
other side of the aisle
to speak up for your point of view
that's not going to happen
but there is a gradation within your
point of view
and that is where the people should be
speaking up unless of course everyone's
taken their point of view
wholesale yeah so this is something that
i think is just so damaging about
grandstanding
uh is that like i said we need people
who are dissenters within their group to
be able to speak up there should be a
low cost
uh to asserting an unpopular belief or
to challenging
the orthodoxy uh because when there is a
low cost
of doing so uh so sorry i'm again being
academic so what i mean is
um people are not no they don't
uh when it's safe for people to speak up
and express doubt they're more likely to
do so and the result
is people then get to engage with a
challenge to their view and what you
emerge with hopefully
uh is a a more strongly justified
belief rather than just a comfortable
orthodoxy that becomes
uh what john stewart mill would call a
dead dogma so it's something people
believe
they forget why they believed it uh but
they're not gonna question it
i love that a dead dog from it man i
iron sharp and zion that's why
yeah having good conversations is is
real important
what were some of the most extreme
examples of grandstanding that you found
the one where
someone tweeted that a two-year-old
eaten by a crocodile
shouldn't deserve sympathy because she
was sick of white men's entitlement
seemed yeah a bit mental yeah right so
what
this is like a kid got killed by an
alligator right oh and then like because
like uh i think there had been a
shooting or something recently and
people were like oh yeah well i mean
we're down on white people right now so
like to the credit of
of the mob like this this was seen as
finally too far
okay all right so that one was outside
of the overton window
in terms of extremity yeah well but
within a certain
group uh probably fine it was like great
yeah
exactly yeah white man i'm yeah time for
some of these white men to get eaten by
alligators right
no the white men are two-year-old
two-year-old daughters yeah and their
children
yeah too exactly right what were some of
the other ones what was some of the more
extreme
or the extreme examples that you found
yeah uh so gamergate is always always a
good one
for this um so this was um uh
this is still very difficult for me to
explain um because i think this is like
one of the first like nerd culture
things that became
sort of mainstream and it was just like
not explained very well
but this was uh basically like people
started um
getting worked up about um
two things about both kind of cozy
relationships between
game publishers and game critics uh so
that that like the reviews were just
sort of like industry pieces about like
why this is a great thing and you need
it but also
um about games becoming too political so
you know um games like shoehorning in
representation of trans characters or
like lesbian
characters or things like this anyway um
a feminist media critic kind of called
attention to a lot of like the toxic
um responses uh from people who didn't
like the politics
at least i i'm gonna get emails now
people correcting me no that's not what
it's about it's really about it
the the internet corrects everyone
we're here to be corrected yeah i know
it um but anyway so i mean people were
sending her death threats
um just like you know oh wow like
everyone's calling her [ __ ] online and
you know saying she needs to get raped
and um you know she's so it's
anita sarkeesian she's collected all of
these like horrible
uh responses and you know so how how do
you explain this
it's not all grandstanding right some of
it is is actually just people
being crazy and like psychos but you
know you can see why for someone in a
certain community
um the thing to do is express like
extreme disdain
for this person who is a threat to their
like cherished beliefs
about what video games should be
something like this
um so so yeah so it's like a high status
move within that group
to come up with like the most
misogynistic thing or whatever to
to say to this woman um and so as a
result you get these like horrible
pylons um where you know someone has
stepped out of line it's time
you know at least within our group to
correct them wasn't the
wasn't it like the lawyer from a big tv
company had tweeted after the las vegas
shooting
saying that um 847 people have been
injured 120 people have been killed
but most people that listen to country
music a gun toting republican hicks so i
don't really care
yeah yeah right so this is another one
that finally went too far i think but
but yeah there were still people it was
a viral treat people liked this right
because it was like
like i mean okay finally someone willing
to say
uh what the rest of us are thinking this
group is so bad
and they want everyone to have guns
anyway they should get killed by
by the guns um so yeah this is this is
like moral talk
run amok right so the thing that we
point out
the reason we talk about these crazy
examples is that
we think people have this this kind of
naive view that whenever someone is
talking about justice
or whenever someone someone is talking
about like what people deserve
anything that sounds like social justice
or or forget you know
it's not like it's a right left issue
anything that sounds like it's about
morality people think like oh
well this person like their heart is in
the right place like even if they're
wrong they're trying to like
say something important here and it's
not always that way
right so people can actually you can
give a moral evaluation of the way
people use moral talk
and this is what we're doing when we
talk about grandstanding we're saying
like look you can actually think
critically about the way people
are using this practice right and it's
easiest to see
when it's someone going off the deep end
and talking about how kids should get
killed and
things like that but it can also happen
just with everyday ordinary speech uh
when people
uh are using it to look good rather
than to do good and that's what they're
doing with their grandstanding
is grandstanding a moral problem then
it is yeah so um
we give arguments from every major moral
theory
so we point out uh that grandstanding
has bad consequences
some people think morality is all about
the consequences of actions
and if that's your view you should be
really worried about the polarization
that we've talked about
with grandstanding about people becoming
really cynical
about morality and people just uh you
know feeling
outrage exhaustion like oh god i just
can't you know
i everything's outrageous all the time i
can't do it anymore i can't tell
what like is actually outrageous and so
it all stops working
uh there are also arguments that we give
about respect uh so we say
for instance that uh
one of the things people do when they
grandstand again is like pick a target
right and use that person as like a
display model or it's like no one's you
know no one needs this thing
can just beat the hell out of it just to
show everyone you know a demonstration
of our our moral credentials
um and you know uh it doesn't matter
right but of course it does matter
you're not supposed to treat people that
way
uh and even if they deserve it right
even if they've done something bad
like first of all you're probably going
to go too far mob mobs are not known for
their restraint um and you're also just
going to be on the lookout
for opportunities to beat people up like
this so
to use people as an opportunity to
showcase how good you are
and then finally we give some arguments
uh about
moral virtue um my favorite of
these is uh we draw on this uh this
philosopher friedrich nietzsche uh some
of your listeners may be familiar with
it and we say
look um people like a challenge right
uh so nisha says we all have something
he calls the will to power
so we all hate obstacles in a way
right because they're in the way of us
getting what we want but we also need
them
uh because we need that satisfaction
that we get from overcoming
an obstacle of beating a challenge so
you know we all have opportunities to do
this um
in all areas of our life we can actually
do something that's a real achievement
um we can you know do really well at
work
uh we can hit a new personal record in
the gym um
whatever else uh we can also uh
kind of make up a challenge that's
that's just sort of um
you know invented for the purpose of us
achieving something and this is
uh a sort of like a cheat and this is
what people do
with grandstanding we think we we think
they uh
they act as if it's an achievement uh
to say something morally charged uh that
shows what a good person they are
but of course this isn't a real
achievement uh
it's actually just an abuse of morality
so morality is supposed to be about
helping other people
being kind to them about resolving
important social problems
but what grandstanders do is they turn
morality into just an
opportunity to show other people how
good they are and
you know what an achievement for for me
to have such pure moral beliefs
uh but this is an empty achievement and
it's actually kind of pathetic if you
think about it that way
man this this weaponizing
of the
something which at its core should be
really really virtuous
um is is really worrying and he's we're
seeing
it a lot at the moment moving into an
area that i know sweet [ __ ] all about
why
is grandstanding a particular problem in
politics
because i can talk about the uh a way
that someone perhaps should
uh maximize their own agency in life and
and use their sovereign will to become
the things that they can be
um i just i haven't started to
draw that perspective out to kind of the
collective
uh and i found it really interesting
that you guys did discuss how
grandstanding
acts as a problem in politics sure so
um politics is heavily moralized now
everyone wants to see that their
politicians have good character
this isn't really new again but
now i think it's it's probably even more
common because people uh like to feel
like they have this
personal relationship with their
politicians probably because of social
media
so politicians have this strong
incentive to
show people how good they are now that
might be good right
it's good for people to be informed uh
it's good for people to know what
they're getting
when uh they vote for someone but
again just because someone says
something doesn't mean
that it actually is good information
right
or uh that it sets up good incentives
for them
uh to actually do their job once they're
in office
so a couple of problems that come up
here
one is that in democracies we have
kind of split representation of
viewpoints in government
we need our representatives to be able
to work together and compromise
to give up you know something that's
kind of on the periphery
of what we care about in order to
achieve
a solution to the the really big problem
so we need them to
have a little bit of leeway a little bit
of flexibility but once politicians
start taking
strong moral stances because they're
incentivized to do so
they lose some of this this flexibility
they uh are expected then
not to give an inch and because of this
they can't then work together and give
up a little to get a lot
right so instead you know we see this
especially in the states right now
where at least our last couple of
presidents have governed by executive
order
because it's such a popular position in
among legislators to say you know i'm
not working with those people they're
corrupt
and if you do it's again chum in the
water right because
you're the black sheep everybody sees
you're not reliable you
seem not principled because you're
willing to
to compromise uh and so this is this is
really dangerous right
so it makes democracy really
dysfunctional the other thing
that that happens so much in politics uh
is that if you turn like political
action into a morality pageant um
you create incentives for politicians to
look like
um they're doing something really
morally good that people can see
immediately their heart is in the right
place
uh even if it turns out for you know com
you know complicated like nerdy reasons
uh it doesn't work right so
uh effectively then politicians
start to uh propose what we call
expressive policies
so these are policies that on the face
of it sound really good
they make it clear uh well at least if
the person sincere that the person
proposing the policy their heart is in
the right place they care a lot about
the issue
uh but they don't actually work so all
they end up doing is being a symbolic
gesture
so a good example of this is rent
control every economist
recognizes brand control does not work
it does not actually rent control
rent control is uh setting a limit on
how much landlords can
can raise uh the price of rent uh
basically on
on uh putting a ceiling on what people
end up paying
for rent so i mean what could be bad
about that right
it sounds great like you look at your
lease you're like i wish that number was
lower
and rent control promises to give you
that very thing
but the problem is when and you see this
over and over again in cities that have
imposed rent control
the result is a shortage in affordable
housing
which is you know exactly the uh the
opposite of what we're supposed to get
uh but for complex you know complicated
reasons at least
you know uh sort of complicated reasons
um
landlords you know then see rent uh
see you know um uh
you know housing developments and and
investing and you know making places
you know good to places to live they see
this as
not a good investment right because the
return is limited
by the rent control policy so at least
in the long term what you get is no more
new housing
crumbling old housing and people rushing
to fill you know the the affordable
spaces so you get somewhere like new
york city where people have lived there
for like 80 years or something or
are lying about you know still living
there when it's their great aunt or
something that is
is on the lease and it's just like
gifted it to them um you get people like
this having their
you know 300 a month apartment uh
subsidized by
people who have just moved there paying
like you know 3 000
a month or whatever um so back to
politics i mean
the incentive for politicians is not to
like go through all of this because it's
really boring
right for most people who just want to
pay lower rent
the incentive is for them to to make
people feel like finally
someone is addressing my needs they're
doing something about
uh something i need addressed and so you
get these policies that sound good
and don't work i identified a problem
with sargon of akkad a few weeks ago
about
joe biden's response where he
flip-flopped from
saying that the travel ban from china
at the beginning of kovid was
xenophobic and racist and some other
words
and then two and a half months later
said that trump had done it too late
this to me this entire situation and
that
as a particularly simple example
is so worrying because politicians
should be the best of us
they should be the most virtuous the
most truthful with the most transparency
they should be held to the highest
levels of rigor
they should be the most precise with
their speech everything should be fact
checked
everything should be right well that
that doesn't follow on from the thing
that you said before
whereas when things are simply said for
effect
right now there is i can't
trust what comes out of people's mouths
and unfortunately
as you identified with social media the
people at the top of the tree are
examples for those further down it
and if in an increasingly politicized
society at the moment
people are taking that to be well joe
biden
presidential candidate democratic
nominee if he's able to flip-flop around
his
sort of points of view then why can't i
weaponize my points of view
and i i don't want to live in a world
where people lie
ideally i'd have everyone read take the
red pill online and read sam harris's
book
and never lie at least i'd know where i
[ __ ] stand
but in this situation it seems like as
long as the
as long as the recourse isn't greater
it's like a mathematical equation
if recourse isn't greater than
moral outcome and there's an if function
of like is not um
too conservative then okay to get away
with like you know it's like it's a
weird sort of gated piece of computer
code
but i don't want i don't want the
politicians to be able to say stuff and
and not be not be called out for it man
at all
yeah i mean that's right uh so we do
want to hold people to account
the worry is um that
the incentive is not good for them when
they're held to immediate account so
here's something no one wants to hear
when they're upset about something
we don't have all the information yet we
need to look into this
and then you know do some investigating
figure out what actually happened
uh and then we'll figure out what to do
um
because if you say that the people who
are like screaming for blood immediately
like they
they want a solution right now uh will
be really mad
right so you know we see this problem
with politicians
as primarily one about incentives so we
get what we ask for from politicians
in a democracy so if what we want uh
is just to be comforted
uh to be reassured that the people in
power are good
um will get these these irresponsible
moral proclamations rather than people
being willing
to take a little heat um and and
take their time and do their job right
in ways that we won't immediately
recognize
uh as as them doing their job right how
do we fix this
big problem lots of layers to it there's
political implications there's personal
implications i'm really really concerned
about self-deception
wildly concerned about self-deception
because i think that that restricts
an individual sovereign agency over
themselves
um which is really really pernicious so
what do we what do we do
can you can you fix it for us just
i can't right i can tell you how to how
to help
fix it um so uh the most tempting thing
to do here
probably for most people is you want to
pick up this book grandstanding
and figure out how to find these
grandstanders and go after them and
humiliate them
make them stop it um call them out
but that is exactly the thing that you
should not do
uh so for one thing it won't work uh it
will just be turned right around on you
people will say well actually you're
grandstanding first of all because
people will think any any use of moral
terms at all now
is is grand saying which is is not good
and that is not our view by the way
um but also because they want to defend
the person
in in their tribe right or the person
they agree with and they don't want to
be called
grandstanders themselves uh another
reason not to do this
is you're giving the grand student
exactly what they want they want
public discourse to be about how good
they are
so if you start calling them out for
granted like oh that's very interesting
let's talk about whether i'm a good
person that's you know
that sounds like a great thing for us to
be arguing about
right so so that's no good um so what we
say instead
is uh you should treat this
problem uh as an opportunity to examine
your own behavior
so what you should do about other other
people you think you think they're
grandstanding
is just ignore them right uh because
ignoring someone you think is
grandstanding
is probably no worse than than just like
not being on social media at all
which is not bad um but what you can do
is
when you're about to contribute to some
political discussion
ask yourself am i trying to do good here
or am i just trying to look good
so to give a slightly more fine-grained
test you can run
you can say okay let me imagine
i say this thing i type out this like
you know 3 000 word post or whatever
and then suppose i learned you know a
day later
nobody really cared about me at all they
didn't think anything
uh better of me because of this
i failed to like impress them would i be
disappointed
or or would i instead be comfortable
like well you know at least someone saw
something important morally right
because if you would be disappointed
that you didn't get anything for
yourself
you were probably grandstanding you were
motivated to say that thing
because you wanted recognition and
that's precisely the thing that you
should avoid doing
so uh in other words you know you should
take this book
as an opportunity to examine your own
behavior
and if you don't like what you see maybe
sit one out right uh
self-policing when
there are so many group incentives
to go along with the group i mean the
solution is to sell
7.9 billion copies of grandstanding
which i'm sure that you would be
fantastic i think that sounds ideal
chris
yeah i know everyone everyone wins use
the affiliate link in the in the show
notes below please because i can retire
along with you we can just
cayman islands just grandstanding to
[ __ ] on the top of the the new
plane that we bought um hell yeah but
like that that's a good way for the
people that are listening who are
reasonable
intelligent human beings that want to
try and make themselves and discourse
better
but that doesn't actually get at the
group think
problem that we've got going on here are
you hoping
that simply by not giving them our
attention
that they're going to stop doing it that
seems a little short-sighted
well uh i am taking the long view here
so it probably looks short-sighted um
but here's here's what i think
um so imagine you did that right imagine
like you wrote out
uh a big look to be honest with you i've
i've done this
i've like i've engaged in grandstanding
it's just a human thing
um it does not feel good when you like
take a stab at it
and you get no attention at all right so
the thinking here
is that if enough of us start to ignore
uh this attention seeking behavior it
will come to be seen
as embarrassing so an example that we
give in the book is think of
or rather look into because people
generally don't know about this
look at medieval
[Music]
dining etiquette guides so there are
actually
books in the middle ages uh about how to
behave at the table and it's things like
don't blow your nose in the tablecloth
don't pick up a bone off a serving dish
and like gnaw on it and then put it back
on every you know the food everybody
else is gonna eat it's stuff that's like
what the [ __ ] like what were these
people doing
why did they have to be told any of this
in a book by the way that like only
educated people are gonna read so it's
like unthinkable
that any of this was ever normal
behavior but apparently it was
um so the the hope is
like as crazy as it sounded then
like to get people to like stop blowing
their nose in the tablecloth maybe
maybe that's the position we're now with
grandstanding like
the norms just haven't yet caught up to
the social conditions and they can so
people
people will come to see it as like
really gauche uh to engage in in moral
grandstanding
right it'll be seen as shameful you know
the sort of thing where like
you see you know your your partner doing
it at a dinner party or something like
okay we need we need to go home like
you've had enough
right that's enough wine justin yeah
yeah yeah exactly
yeah so we you know it's not very
satisfying but what we need is for
these good norms to emerge and i uh
in the long run at least i'm hopeful uh
so if grandstanding doesn't destroy the
world first
i think we we will get there so here's
here's a little conception that i was
playing around with recently
i think that the people who are the
funniest
critics and have
created the framework that grandstanders
go through
i'm thinking the james lindsey's of this
world the douglas murrays the andrew
doyles of this world
they have weaponized ridicule and
insight
to counteract this now it's all well and
good us
um saying right i'm just gonna you know
you want my [ __ ] attention mate i'm
not giving it to you
we can chill out what you need to do is
also have it
that is the how would you say
that is the guy
who is getting shot with paintballs and
has a full metal suit on and just
doesn't engage in the game
but what you also need are a couple of
nuclear warheads
who can go in and completely decimate
the battlefield
and make it so toxic for anyone to go
into that area again
perfect example of this think of the
word woke
the word woke now has been flipped on
its head
the same way as the n-word got flipped
in reverse
walk has been flipped on its head again
right
progressive now is almost a term of uh
like a an insult to cause someone a
progressive like it's kind of
it brings up these which is stupid right
because people have tons of progressive
views about all sorts of things
and it'll flip back eventually too well
that's uh was it good
was it goethe that says about we
vacillate between different extremes
no it wasn't it was someone else with a
weird name some other sort of germany
philosopher
saying that we vacillate between
extremes of society and then we kind of
end up
falling into the middle i can't remember
who it was um but yeah
people like douglas murray people like
andrew doyle with his tatani mcgrath
account and his jarvis dupont account
and blah blah blah blah blah
and particularly people like james
lindsay i think
past guest on this show wonderful dude
who
has the playbook of what's going to
happen
because when he can show you
that he knows what that person is going
to do say think
next before they do say or think it you
actually
better than they do themselves holy [ __ ]
this guy this guy isn't playing in
matrix
he's playing in source code he's playing
do you know what i mean
like he's he's got the css terminal up
and he's bootstrapped himself into
what's going on
um here's another thing as well that i
thought when reading grandstanding
that i thought was really interesting i
don't think
that everybody should be allowed to
express an opinion on the internet
i think that previously i
think that there needs to be at the very
least like an over 70
internet i don't know i think i just
think
that the world previously
in order to be able to publish your work
online and have lots and lots of people
see it
you have to have justification for that
to happen
there shouldn't be a reason that any
karen or keith can say a thing
which is sufficiently x
pick your reason that clout occurs
sufficiently outrageous or insulting or
racist or homophobic or progressive or
conservative or whatever it might be
um and it be seen by a couple of hundred
thousand or a couple of million people
that is not the way the human brain is
not designed to confu consume the entire
world's
news instantly it's simple it's too much
information
both incoming to the people that have to
see what karen o'keefe just wrote
and it's um too little friction
for people to be able to get their
thoughts out people are too detached
from the words that they write and the
effect that they have
which leads them to be able to say stuff
that they wouldn't usually like the
number of times that yeah
the only the ultimate answer to most
things
most insults is would you say that to my
face
like of course you wouldn't and then
look at the the particular
instance that we saw with the lady that
was sat down in that restaurant
last week in america like would you say
they did say
would you say it to my face yes but only
if you've got 150 friends with you
yeah yeah yeah right who are also saying
it you know yeah so
all of this stuff compiled together and
the desire for status
and this increasing sense of sort of
melancholy and loneliness that people
have
this lack of grand um connection to the
the natural world which gives us a sense
of perspective about how little and
insignificant we are
and a meritocracy which inevitably means
that if the winners are
virtuous and justified with their
successes that the people who don't have
successes are losers and they
ma i it doesn't surprise me that this
has happened it makes sense that we've
got ourselves to this stage
but as you say being morally outspoken
is not in itself
an achievement and that is the that's
the [ __ ] synopsis
to this book being morally outspoken is
not in itself an achievement so stop
saying that it is stop thinking that it
is
that's right man let me say one thing
about about the
uh titania mcgraths of of the world and
james lindsay
so i mean look my view is like
this actually might be my my most
unpopular belief but like
absolutely anything can be funny uh if
if
uh the person is like talented enough
so uh so i'm a big fan of this podcast
come town
which i think is like you know
exemplifies this this mo of like
absolutely anything can be funny if
you're funny enough
so there are people who are actually
really good uh
at going after uh and shaming
grandstanders
and look yeah norms are really
complicated uh i don't
have like a full view about how they
develop you probably do need some people
uh who are enforcers um but for every
so here's what i'll say about this
though um that behavior is often
emulated by people who are not very good
at it
so for every like actually funny
titanium mcgrath
post if you look at the replies it's
full of like
devastatingly unfunny like cringey
replies of people who think they're
doing it too and they suck
at it so it's like it's okay right you
know
i mean so this is like people people
like
moral rules to be like one size fits all
you know they want to feel like
well why is it okay for them but i can't
do it it's like because you're not
[ __ ] funny man
like so so i think it is still probably
like good
general advice uh and you know even if
people were
good at we don't want people doing that
all the time like because you also need
people who are like polite
and um you know good at building
society everyone was andrew doyle man
jesus yeah oh my god
yeah yeah and then it probably actually
wouldn't even be funny
because the shtick would get worn out
like so quickly but but yeah i mean
yeah i i but i do i do still think like
it's just not a good general turn for us
to start like all
policing each other um at least about
things uh things like grandstanding um
so
moral criticism really important um even
fitting
even when it's it's like done badly
sometimes um
but uh i i think uh the general
the general response to this problem
should be humility uh
rather than going after other people as
fun as it might be
i couldn't agree more the self-deception
thing i just want to finish on that
because
yeah i think it's really really really
important and again like it's the most
it's the scariest part of all of this
for me
um yeah and upon
realizing all of the different layers
that our evolution
has left in us that means that we really
really are
significantly unconscious about why we
do so many of the things that we do
with regards to reciprocal altruism or
why we're attracted or disattracted to
our partner and blah blah blah blah blah
like the murky waters of stepping into
your own programming and
choosing your wants and desires
carefully is made
worse when you allow people to weaponize
morality
and you start to go along with it like
our job should be a
should be to try and see our desires and
the way that we operate as transparently
as possible
as far as i'm concerned you want to live
a a life which is very consciously
designed because
there's a ton of stuff which you really
really don't want and if you're not
careful you'll end up in a place not
only that you didn't mean to get to but
you don't want to be
and yet if you are too
[Music]
uh at the mercy of
group think and this kind of moral
grandstanding
you make the waters murky rather than
clearer that's
my my thought what are you going to say
yeah i mean
i i tend to agree with you so i find a
lot of um
like the evolutionary psychology stuff
kind of unsettling for the same reasons
like i you know nobody likes to
especially to be told
um you know you think you're in the
driver's seat here
but like actually there it's like your
lizard brain you know it's like
these deep-seated impulses you're
completely unaware of um
i think so i think uh i guess i agree
with you
that uh up to a point it's it's good to
like be in control and actually aware
of what you're doing and uh it's an
important part of like being an
autonomous
human being uh but there are also like
things about us
like there's a reason we are this way
right so
it is an adaptive trait still for for us
to engage in a little bit of
self-deception
um so i mean yeah i mean reiterate it
like
it is i think good to be in control of
your life and not just a complete slave
to your impulses and and things that are
beneath your your subconscious
um but it's also an impossible goal to
chase
complete uh complete awareness and
control yeah i mean yeah
i didn't think you uh i i agree i think
that's i think that's actually a really
good point that i haven't considered and
i think it's
partly because i'm swimming in eve psych
at the moment so i'm like just
i don't have i i have such
little faith in my own constitution
um because of it uh but you are right it
is an adaptive trait
and having faith
that the wisdom of
whatever a couple of ten thousand
generations
or whatever of uh of humans or a
thousand generations you know ten
thousand ten thousand generation
of uh of humans two hundred and fifty
thousand is ish roundabout right
um yeah um
some of the stuff despite the fact we're
in a new environment and all the rest of
it like there's some things that are
still going to be effective
so actually i really i really like that
man that's a good uh
that's a a good little sort of reversal
to
to the things that i've been thinking
about recently dude it's been it's been
it's been really really fun
uh the book grandstanding will be linked
in the show notes below
any of the stuff that you want to drive
people to any other places on the
internet that they should go to check
out your stuff
uh i mean you can follow me on twitter
uh or my co-author brandon warmkey uh
we're easy to find
uh we will we'll post our our op-eds and
other
public things there if you want to
follow our work
so we're still working on grandstanding
stuff we're doing a lot of empirical
work now testing
uh some of the the speculative but
well-founded of course claims that that
we make in the book and
you know so far we're just right about
don't you love everything when that
happens dude it's great yeah it's so
satisfying philosophers we mostly just
just like make things up and make it
untestable but like for this project
brandon and i are like no let's let's
like engage with reality and like put
ourselves out there and
like it's working so far so i hope it
keeps on working dude
thanks dan thanks so much for your time
hey thank you
you